85 aujourd'hui et oui joyeux
anniversaire au dette
[Musique]
où
j'étais content c'est un beau garçon si
j'avais encore 20 ans s'est tout de
suite libéré tout s'est défendue
c'est parti sur des rires tout de suite
et est vraiment la voir avec ce sourire
c'est quelque chose qui était important
sinon procuré beaucoup de voleurs
chevillard ans un appartement moi j'ai
des huit semaines sans voir personne
parce que c'était interdit qui
s'approche de moi j'étais trop sensible
pour cette maladie alors personnes
venaient me voir je vous jure ça m'a
touché parce que c'est long quand on
voit personne mais les dix frères des
pauvres et nous oublient jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces longs mois non il y aurait bien sûr
qui est ramenée dans les jardins olibeau
aussi d'être connus a claqué avec elle à
96 ans et je vais poser la question de
savoir ce qui était le plus simple entre
guillemets à vivre entre la guerre un
confinement et elle m'a confié que pour
s avait été plus simple de vivre la
guerre et j'ai leur grand-mère qui était
concerné par ça allait aller en ehpad
c'est exactement ce que vivent les
personnes âgées
ma grand mère on a pu faire des appels
vidéo skype et j'en ai profité pour
faire la même chose avec odette et une
petite anecdote c'est que j'en ai parlé
à odette et à chaque fois que l'on a
discuté ensemble elles vont donner des
nouvelles de ma grand-mère donc ça va
vraiment touché et très plaisir
[Musique]
odette le dit elle-même sa seule famille
sélectif en des pauvres donc aller
complètement isolé isolé depuis depuis
longtemps et donc par contre ça fait
longtemps que faire des pauvres les
équipes viennent la voir qu'elle
participe à noël qu'elle participe à des
vacances est en place et est en plus de
la mêlée volts hyper la loire
habituellement balle a pu avoir un
nouveau contact discuter avec des
personnes âgées
ça me rappelle énorme l'enfance j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps
ce qui manque dans l'école c'est avec
eux partent en vacances à les personnes
âgées sont en général beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus réaliste lucide sur ce
qu'elles sont et ont pas peur de le dire
et ont ils permettent souvent d'avoir
des conseils précieux dirait qu'elles
ont souvent plus d'ailleurs le sens de
la conversation
elles n'ont pas eu usage des réseaux
sociaux donc la conversation en vrai en
fait elles savent prendre des nouvelles
s'intéressait à vous est d'ailleurs très
souvent dans les premières relations
c'est plus souvent les personnes âgées
qui pose des questions aux bénévoles que
l'inversé
[Musique]
le conseil que j'ai à donner aux jeunes
c'est osé la rencontre avec les
personnes âgées elles sont riches d'une
expérience qu'elle ne demande qu'à
transmettre
elles sont aussi très capable d'écouté
de compréhension de bons conseils
elles ont une forme souvent de sagesse
que leur donne l'expérience de vie ce
sont souvent des exemples de courage et
aussi de force de vie de capacité à
exprimer des désirs jusqu'au bout et ça
je pense que quand on n'est pas bien
voir leur courage leur envie leur
capacité à rire encore leurs envies de
joie c'est vraiment des choses
extrêmement importantes et qui sont
essentiels je lui souhaite tout le bien
que je peux dans son dans son travail
quand il s'entraîne quand et puis il va
prendre sa sortie garçons